the premise of the movie is set in the
late period of the chinese dynasty named
kin a group of bandits is partying in
the desert after robbing a town the main
attraction of the party is a beautiful
woman who they have abducted for their
pleasure the leader doesn't let anyone
touch her wanting to save her for
himself she is taken into a room where
he promises to give her anything she
wants even his heart the woman
seductively touches his chest before
ripping his heart out in an instant it
is revealed that her name is mina and
she is an evil fox spirit who feasts on
human hearts to maintain her youthful
appearance she frequently uses her charm
to seduce powerful or evil men their
hearts have more chakra than the others
which she uses to manifest an orb it is
a special weapon at her disposal which
can be used to kill people and even
bring them back to life at the same time
the bandits are attacked by a great
warrior named general wang and his
soldiers they defeat the bandits in a
fierce battle that goes on for hours
wang finds mina half naked in a room and
sympathizes with her he gives her a
cloth to cover herself and carries her
to a horse unaware of her true identity
the soldiers also welcome mina and bring
her back to their town mina has never
felt compassion from any man which makes
her actually fall in love with wang
however upon reaching the town she sees
that he has a wife named peirong who
loves him very much she welcomes him
back happy that he wasn't hurt in the
battle she is also glad to see a new
companion but the same cannot be said
for mina she starts living a new life
and settles into the general's residence
during this time she falls deeper in
love with wang but is troubled by her
growing friendship with payron a month
later someone breaks into the town's
entrance at night wang goes out to look
for the intruder and finds him
unconscious it is none other than his
old friend and former general yang they
know he is not a threat to the town and
its people hence they bring him back to
the general's residence and provide him
with proper medical treatment payron is
shocked to see yang and is worried about
him it turns out that before she married
wang she and yang used to be a couple
but he left his people after a battle
and never returned at night peyrong
registers that yong's arrival has been
bothering her husband she assures wang
that he is the only person she loves
things start getting steamy but when
wang looks back at her face he sees
mina shocked he wakes up and realizes it
was only a dream what he doesn't know is
that mina is making him fall in love
with her subconsciously meanwhile she is
in her room she refuses to eat dinner
and sends a maid away then arrives a
male spirit named xiaowei with raw
hearts for her to eat he is mina's
friend who has been helping her by
bringing a human heart every day so she
can maintain her beauty without being
suspected but the frequent deaths and
dead bodies with missing hearts have
sparked several rumors in the town wang
has tightened the security and is trying
his best to find the culprit the next
day yong wakes up and finds payron
taking care of him he apologizes for
arriving out of the blue and blames it
on the alcohol he drank that night wang
asks him to stay in the town and help
them find the murderer but he refuses
later at night yong meets a strange
woman in the town's restaurant and
befriends her her name is xia and she is
a demon hunter yang who doesn't believe
in demons thinks nothing of her
profession then they are joined by
peyron who has begun to suspect mina of
being a demon because the murders
started on the day she came to town
moreover she recalls the time when they
were working at a cosmetic shop and mina
calmed down a rude customer just by
asking her to keep quiet it was almost
as if she could hypnotize people
payron's suspicion was confirmed when
she accidentally cut mina's palm with
scissors but it didn't bleed she has
even taken mina to a temple to ensure
she isn't a spirit but being in the holy
place didn't affect her payron wants
yong's help to solve the case because
she knows her husband will laugh at her
if she mentions the existence of spirits
shia is intrigued by the rumored demon
and is happy to have an exciting case on
her hands in the following scene yang
goes to the cemetery where the dead
bodies of the recent murders are kept
the precision of the cut in them makes
it clear the killer is skilled he also
finds shia resting inside one of the
coffins and asks her to get out she
shows them a magical stone that glows in
the presence of a demon within a 10 mile
radius shia has come to the town using
the stone but she hasn't been able to
find the spirit yet upon further
investigation they discover that all the
murders have happened around the
general's residence this makes them even
more suspicious of mina coincidentally
at night yong runs into xiaowei who is
about to attack shia they get into a
chase but xiaowei manages to run away
shia hurts her leg and has to be taken
care of by yang they don't know what
xiaowei's intention was but come to the
conclusion that he was just a thief
shias shows yang a demon stick that was
a gift from her grandfather no one has
been able to take the cap off the stick
yet it is said that only a true demon
hunter can do so yong gives it a try but
fails the next day yang xia and the
commander who is helping them out go to
wang and tell them about mina wang looks
at his wife in disappointment knowing
that she is the one who spread the rumor
he doesn't believe in demons and is
strictly against accusing an innocent
girl of murdering people still the
others pressure him to do an inspection
to confirm or deny the accusations most
of the soldiers are on mina's side since
she has wooed them with her beauty and
sweetness yong tries to cut her hand to
prove otherwise but wang stops him he
declares that the girl is innocent but
his wife stands against him she wants to
check her for a demon birthmark that is
bound to be somewhere on her body the
women take her into a room and strip her
naked but cannot find the mark wang asks
everyone to go away after that he is
especially mad at his wife for letting
jealousy take the best of her he makes
her apologize but in turn mina asks her
to let her be wang's mistress both wang
and peyrong are shocked at the demand
wang gets up and declares that there can
only be one first lady and he already
has one he tells mina he cares about her
but he cannot betray his wife later that
night wang dreams of walking to meena
who is taking a bath inside of a cave he
sees himself making love to her and
wakes up covered in sweat
then he goes to her room to talk meena
tries to slide her gown off but he stops
her he thinks that she is too good to be
someone's mistress and instead deserves
a loving husband when she asks him to be
her husband he tells her how much he
loves pay wrong suddenly xiaowei attacks
them he has developed an unrequited love
for mina and is furious that wang is
making her cry in the end the soldiers
are alerted and he has to run away
however during the commotion payron
notices that her husband was in mina's
room she is ready to give him up if he
is also in love with her wang tells her
he is not interested but sees through
his lies when mina meets xiaowei again
later he confesses that he is in love
with her this angers her even more after
he tried to kill the person she loves he
tells her that love between demons and
humans is impossible but mina asks him
to go away and never show his face again
later peyron goes to meena's room
deciding to allow her to be wang's
mistress however to her surprise she
catches mina peeling off her human skin
she proudly shows her real face after 20
years not afraid of being exposed it is
a horrible sight that makes payron's
skin crawl suddenly they are interrupted
by a soldier and mina kills him as well
when paerong asks her to stop she
presents her with an offer she is
willing to never kill a single human in
her life if peyron walks away from
wang's life and never returns to save
her people peyron reluctantly agrees to
do as she says then she is made to drink
a poison that makes her skin and hair
white giving her an inhuman look outside
the soldiers find her and assume that
she is the demon that has been killing
people the entire town sees her new face
and throws stones at her payron doesn't
speak up for herself ready to sacrifice
her life for others just before she is
killed yong saves her and brings her to
a cave nearby he doesn't trust her when
she says she is a demon shia confirms
that she recognizes her symptoms as the
side effect of a poison as they think of
the next step wang arrives with the
soldiers and is shocked to see his wife
in such a situation as the general he is
obligated to kill her for her crimes but
as her husband he cannot do it payron
tells him that she killed everyone but
he declares that he loves her as a human
and as a demon in the end she impales
herself on his sword and dies wang is
devastated he holds her body and cries
in agony mina tries to sympathize with
him by moving closer but he takes no
notice of her and continues to sob while
holding on to pay wrong this is when
mina realizes that wang will never truly
love her no matter what she does right
then yang hits mina with his sword and
proves that she is the real demon when
the weapon does her no harm but at this
point mina doesn't care that her cover
is blown wang begs her to bring his wife
back to which she asks him what she will
get in return not wanting to live a life
without pay wrong wang commits the
unthinkable mina breaks down into tears
and manifests her power orb to life it
is the formation of chakra that she has
collected throughout her life that has
the power to bring back the dead she
tries using it on wang but is stopped by
xiaowei he steals the orb because if
mina uses it she will go back to her
most primal form moreover the orb is the
result of thousands of years of hard
work and he doesn't want her to waste it
on a man young attacks xiaowei and a
fierce battle ensues between the two
this time yong has shaw by his side who
knows how a demon can be killed she
brings out her grandfather's weapon and
tries to open it one last time to her
surprise she does the unpredicted and
takes the cap off then she attacks
xiaowei and finally kills him but right
after yang dies because of his injuries
she weeps asking him to come back as the
two had started to like each other at
last shia walks to mina to end her life
once and for all however she sees that
both xiaowei and her orb are in front of
her now mina uses them to give life back
to everyone who died in the cave as wang
wakes up he sees mina fade into
nothingness he runs to his wife and is
relieved to see that she is alive a few
days later everything goes back to
normal in the town wang wants yang to
stay in the town and help the soldiers
but he has decided to accompany shia in
her demon hunt mission to the south in
the last scene we see that mina has
manifested in her white fox form she has
no power to return to her former self
but her memories are still intact
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching